I have six numbers here and you see that
five of them are irrational there they
involve the square root of a non perfect
square and my goal or our goal in this
video is without a calculator see if we
can sort these numbers from least to
greatest and like always pause this
video and see if you can do that so I'll
give you a hint the hint is it's very
hard without a calculator you know
square root of 2 it's going to be one
point something something square root
three is going to be one point something
something how do we do this but you just
have to realize if I have some number
let's say I have some number a that is
greater than zero and if we know that a
is less than B well then a squared is
going to be less than B squared if one
number
if one positive number is less than
another positive number then the square
of this positive number is going to be
less than the square of that number so
one thing that we could do when we're
when we are comparing all of these
irrational numbers that involve square
roots of non perfect squares
well let's compare their squares because
their squares are not going to be
irrational numbers it's going to be much
easier to compare and then we can order
them because if we order the squares
then we can we tell us what happens if
we order their square roots so what am I
talking about
well I'm just going to square each of
these so if I take this to the second
power this is going to be four square
roots of two times 4 square roots of 2
you can change the order of
multiplication that's 4 times 4 times
the square root of 2 times the square
root of 2 now 4 times 4 is 16 square
root of 2 times square root of 2 well
that's just going to be 2 so it's going
to be 16 times 2 which is equal to 32
now what about 2 square roots of 3 well
same idea it's 2 let's square it let's
square it and I'll do this one a little
bit faster so if we square 2 square
roots of 3 this is going to be 2 squared
times square root of 3 squared so it's
going to be 2 squared times the square
root of 3 squared well 2 squared is
going to be 4
our square root of three squared is
going to be three so this is going to be
equal to this is going to be equal to
twelve that's this thing this thing
squared and if you don't if this step
seems a little bit confusing if you have
the product of two things raised to a
power that's the same thing as raising
each of them to that power and then
taking the product and you can actually
see I kind of worked it out here why
that actually makes sense
notice when I just changed the order of
multiplication you had four times four
or four squared times square root of two
squared which is going to be two so
let's keep doing that so what is this
value squared well it's going to be 3
squared which is nine times square root
of 2 squared which is 2 9 times 2 is 18
what's the square root of 17 squared
well that's just going to be 17 then in
blue this is just going to be this is
just going to be 17 what is 3 square
roots of 3 squared well it's going to be
3 squared which is 9 times square root
of 3 squared the square root of 3 times
the square root of 3 is 3 so it's going
to be 9 times 3 or 27 and what is 5
squared well that's this is pretty
straightforward that's going to be 25 so
let's order them from least to greatest
so which of them when I square it gives
me the smallest value well the SMAW
compared 32 to 12 to 18 to 17 to 27 to
25 12 is the smallest value so if their
square is a small so these are all
positive numbers and this is going to be
the smallest value out of all of them so
let me write that first so 2 square
roots of 3 so I've covered that one now
what's next well now I have this value
17 is the next smallest is the next
smallest square so it's square root is
going to be the next smallest or the
next square root so it's going to be 2
square roots of 3 then square root of 17
that is this one here then we go to 18
so if we look at its square root would
numbers we were originally trying to
sort that be square roots three square
roots of three let's the right-side 3
square roots of 2 3 square roots of 2 we
got that one covered then the next one
is going to be 25 when you look at the
squares so the next value out of our
original set the next largest one is
going to be 5 so then we get to 5 we've
covered that one then the next one let's
see we have 27 and 32 left so the next
largest one it's going to be the 27 is
the next largest square so the next
largest number out of the ones we care
about is 3 square roots of 3 so 3 square
roots of 3 we cover that one and then we
finish with this is the largest value
for square roots of 2 for square roots
of 2 and we're done that was pretty neat
without a calculator we were able to
sort these irrational numbers these vat
of these these numbers well not all of
them are irrational but the ones that
involved a square root of something that
is not a perfect square